and now I'd like to present our speaker
today professor Giuliano V Hilda Slee
Giulia Novi Hilda Slee is professor of
the practice and executive director of
Stanford's
change leadership for sustainability
programs this includes the leadership
for sustainability executive education
program as well as a sustainability
science and practice interdisciplinary
master's degree with 20 years experience
leading nonprofit and philanthropic
organizations
Julia's research and teaching focuses on
business strategies leadership
approaches and cross-sector partnerships
that spur global development in the line
systems with the goal of
intergenerational well-being the change
leadership program explores the mindsets
knowledge and tools leaders need to
accelerate the transition to a more
sustainable and resilient societies
these include understanding complex
systems leading organizational change
and innovating in complex systems at
scale in order to shift sub-optimal
status quo orientation toward
sustainability and jewelry we'll be
talking about some of these themes today
throughout the webinar so with that I'd
like to turn it over to Julia hello
there and welcome to webinar glad to
have you joining us today I'm going to
cover three core questions and being
first why build a sustainable
organization second what orientations
are required to thrive in today's
operating environment and learn how to
integrate sustainability at the core and
throughout your organization so let's
start first by talking about
sustainability and what's the thing that
already means sustainability is really a
term that has often been associated with
green concepts and doing environmental
good in it but in fact if you look at
really what sustainability means more
broadly it's a very holistic systemic
definition that's important to consider
so for example economic social and
environmental factors we hear when
business talks about the triple
bottom-line the Brundtland report is the
first report that really made an effort
in 1987 to define what sustainable
development is and it looked at the
interactions between human beings and
their natural environment basically
saying that environment is the place
where we live and development is what we
do within that environment and therefore
sustainable development is thinking
about how we go about improving our
condition while maintaining the quality
of the environment where we live another
really important thing to remember about
sustainability in addition to it being a
holistic term incorporating social
economic and environmental values is
that it is a long-term view on
development and it's a very integrated
view so for example it is not just about
some folks doing well at the expense of
others but it's really about holistic
view of all people doing well and it's
about doing well over time across
generations we often use the term
intergenerational well-being to
subscribe what we mean by sustainability
so one can't really understand
sustainability without thinking about
systems and here in this diagram you see
the economy nested within society and
nested within the environment when you
think about systems you think about
complex nonlinear dynamic interactions
that occur between economy society and
the environment Jane Jacobs an urban
philosopher reminds us that the
environment the economy is a wholly
owned subsidiary of the environment and
not the other way around so with this in
mind we have to move a little bit from
maybe our more linear reductive
approaches to problem solving and
thinking and take a more holistic
systemic view this cartoon shows a group
of blind men with an elephant working to
understand what they're looking at and
of course they're all looking at
different parts separately and getting
fragmented views of what's going on
it's like taking a systems perspective
and exchanging information about
different parts of the system that they
can come to a full understanding let's
talk about how we here in business the
global environment characterized with
the world is a concept that was coined
by the US Army War College
to describe the multilateral world after
the Cold War where things were much more
in flux and it has been used now since
the late 1990s in business to describe
the volatility uncertainty complexity
and acuity of the business operating
environment and really if you look at
some of the root causes of VUCA world we
see the underlying these symptoms are
the dynamic interactions between social
environmental systems and increasing
stress we face within those systems
whether from population growth or
technology change or climate issues and
resource scarcity civic strife or
political unrest these dynamics of the
social environmental systems are giving
rise to the context we call bucha so
given the fifth circuit our eyes by
complexity let's look a little bit more
closely at what differentiates
complicated from complex environments or
complicated challenges from complex
challenges complicated challenges are
ones where the problem is easily
definable where this you know how is
adequate you can solve the challenge
with an existing blueprint or algorithm
or procedure you're in a fairly stable
context where outcome is fairly
predictable you can plan for change and
success depends on the blueprint of
direct both in development of separate
parts and specifies the exact
relationship in which to assemble them
so you can think of a Ferrari as as a
complicated system you can take the part
to hit all the cars and while it's very
very complex you can put it back
together and the sum is simply equal to
two the parts in a complex environment
or challenge only parts of the problem
are definable expertise help in the same
way helps in a complicated challenge but
it has to be response with
responsiveness because the environment
is changing the contest is unstable the
outcome is unpredictable
and this of course means that it
requires constant adaptation
improvisation and experimentation and in
this case you can't really separate the
parts from the whole the essence
actually exists in the relationships
between the parts so you can think about
the tropical rainforest for example
where you have all the different species
together in dynamic interaction with one
another and if you take it all apart you
will see that actually the sum is much
greater than the individual part because
of the interaction so the rain for
example creases rain on its own in cycle
nutrients all of these functions happen
because of the interactions between the
different parts so here's a little
cartoon that maybe expresses our
temptation to sometimes look for the
simple answers when we are overwhelmed
in guca context and that we are
grappling with how best to deal with
complexity and to find the patterns of
navigation that will help us find our
way through complexity to the divisions
we hope to achieve
davus noting in the late-1990s work to
try to help us in this regard he
developed the Kineton framework and
everything is it worth it means habitat
in Welsh and you can see at the top left
we have environments characterized by
complexity so what the kinetic framework
does is it categorizes different
habitats or contexts and the aim is to
help decision-makers and managers really
understand the different contexts they
might be in and then apply the right
problem-solving approaches or strategies
based on that context so if you look at
the complex context in the upper left
quadrant what you can see is that we
need to apply intuitive navigation of
changing patterns we need to look at
pattern management as a dominant
strategy when dealing with complexity
and that by definition means of really
strong capacity to sense the environment
to perceive patterns and to respond and
experiment accordingly based on that
strong sensing capacity if we look at
natural
ecological systems these systems like
the tropical rainforest have millions of
years of experience navigating changing
patterns in the context of complexity
and change and it's an interesting
question to consider whether or not
understanding of it how the organisms
within a complex open natural system
like the rainforest and the system
itself orient could perhaps help
business and organizations think about
how they might orient in the context of
change and complexity so let's look at
some of the core orientations of resort
we're going open natural systems first
of all they are oriented to connect they
have rich patterns of relationships and
very much of an interconnected
interdependent communication between the
different elements
they also oriented to adapt to evolve
and adapt to changing conditions to be
in touch through the sensing capacitive
connection with what's going on in the
environment and then to adapt
accordingly to explore new niches or to
evolve to suit a change in condition and
then finally they're oriented to
innovate to experiment and redesign to
identify new ways of behaving and
designing oneself in the context of a
new environment so when you're thinking
about building a sustainable
organization it's both about thinking
and placing sustainability at the core
with purpose but also applying the kinds
of orientations that really enable an
organization to thrive in the context of
complexity and change so you can see in
this diagram the idea that applying
orientations of connect adapting
innovate expands the capacity of the
organization if you have impact through
its core purpose so let's talk a little
bit about what those orientations might
look like in the context of business so
connect for example would be about broad
and deepening connections the broaden
one's view seeing one's connection to
the broader context and operating
environment and then deepening the
connection say for example through one's
value chains to have more of a
relationship focus rather than a
transaction focus to really understand
the operations more deeply and build the
relationships accordingly it's about
them being the environment in which are
operating from a holistic perspective
and that includes seeing all the
connections as well as seeing places
maybe with our disconnection to where
the system is broken adapt is really
about learning and reorienting to be
relevant being relevant to the changing
context that means seeing this fuller
understanding of reality that you get by
greater connections and then expanding a
notion of responsibility because of that
understanding so that may be moving from
a focus on shareholder as the dominant
and only stakeholder to a much more
broad and inclusive view of stakeholders
it may mean moving from a shorter term
focus on financial profitability to a
more inclusive longer term focus on
social environmental and economic
sustainability and then in terms of
innovate it's really about thinking
creatively about the opportunities
presented by the new context and
designing and partnering for
sustainability taking some
responsibility for the ways in which the
system isn't working and jumping in and
redesigning system so that they can work
in this new context and aligned with
sustainability goals so in a moment
we're going to talk about a couple of
organizations look at two examples of
organizations that have put
sustainability at the core and apply
these orientations to expand the impact
and profitability of their organizations
but first I'd like to do a quick poll
and check in with our group here about
some of the motivations and that might
be behind your interest in your
organization's interest in engaging
sustainability so what I'd like to ask
you or what are the main driver
for integrating sustainability into the
core purpose of your organization
there's a set of options there to choose
from these are based on the reports a
comprehensive report submitted to the
Harvard Business Review and published
last fall that really look at the
academic research and data that has been
for you know the last couple of decades
as to why companies are putting
sustainability at the core I'd be
interested to hear what's motivating
your organization to do so to the extent
that it is so we'll pause for moments
take some answers and then we'll in a
minute or two be able to report back on
the poll say well close the port looks
as though fostering innovation is one of
the leading reasons and driving
competitive advantage as well as
attracting and engaging employees that
looks like that also received quite a
large number but all all of the choices
were selected thank great thank you so
let's look at a couple of case studies
from Unilever a multinational consumer
goods company which reaches 2 billion
customers per day and has over a hundred
seventy thousand toys and sustainable
harvest a specialty coffee importer that
imports about 20 million pounds of
coffee per year and is responsible for
about one sixth of the Fairtrade coffee
sold in the United States so let's look
at the orientation that they're applying
with sustainability as their core
purpose and see what that actually means
is that you translate that to business
so first of all the connect orientation
they are broadening their view looking
at the broader context and also
deepening connections and they're doing
this in three ways that I'd like to
discuss today one they're situating
their organization in the broader
context understanding the role they play
in that context and how that context
might affect them second they're
building relationships across their
value chain and third they're connecting
their core purpose to the current
reality so they're ensuring an alignment
between them there's four service
in the context they're operating in
second the adapt orientation this is
really about learning and reorienting to
be relevant so in the first place where
we are any goals and strategy to align
with the new sustainability orientation
and the contextual changes but they're
also putting a place metric to measure
progress second they're aligning culture
and instead of the phrase with culture
often Trump strategy is important here
in that without a culture that's
supportive of this realignment and it's
learning sustainability strategy will
likely not be as effective and then
finally adopting a learning orientation
throughout the organization third
innovating you all selected fostering
innovation is one of the core reasons
for putting sustainability at the core
of your organization this really is
about designing and partnering for
sustainability first through new
products and business models second by
engaging broad participation in problem
solving so harnessing a lot more
resources dedicated to that innovation
and then finally for new partnerships
new kinds of partnerships
perhaps with unlikely bedfellows to
achieve scaled impact so was speaking to
Unilever a little bit as you probably
know Unilever is an angled Dutch
transnational consumer goods company it
touches two billion customers per day
and the CEO Paul Polman was began his
tenure in 2009 and built on the
traditional values of Unilever but
really began as very powerful InFocus
emphasis on sustainability focusing on
growing and prospering by tackling 21st
challenge 21st century challenges
actually seeing as you pointed out in
the poll that by tackling these
challenges innovation and and therefore
productivity growth would wouldn't
encourage at which would increase so one
of the first things you talk about we're
taking a different approach he said
business need to take more consistent
approach to their operations seeing
companies as part of an interconnected
web of links multiple players
so this is how he began his approach and
for a to thinking about operating a
business in service of sustainability so
the first element of situating in
broader context aligned with the
connected orientation Unilever conducted
a thorough strategic review and
identified four main mega trends that
affected its business the first has to
do with shift in markets the world
moving south and east in other words a
strong shift to emerging markets but
then recognizing that within these
markets there were constraints related
to income and resource scarcity that
would have impact on the business second
and stiff and lifestyles living
differently a big move of globally from
rural to urban locations which then put
this into question taxing and already
strained infrastructure with this urban
migration also longer lives people
living longer all of these had
implications for supply chains and
products and service design third the
environment under stress shifts in the
natural environment
recognizing water scarcity climate
change deforestation poor sanitation
that the operating conditions for
business were increasingly under stress
which had big implications for product
developments and manufacturing as well
as supply chain security issues and then
finally the digital revolution
looking at shift in stakeholder
empowerment through access to
information communication technologies
in particular recognizing that citizens
who were empowered through these
technologies required more transparency
and stakeholder engagement and that was
required in order to minimize the
reputational risk and the demand for
more stringent regulations that business
might suffer if it didn't effectively
EJC stakeholders so in addition to
connecting with the broader context
Unilever also has placed a very strong
emphasis on connecting throughout
value-chain so not just the broader
global environment but then really
looking across all of its value chains
and thinking about the relationships
with suppliers and the impact of the
products within that value chain so one
step Coleman took early on was to ask
his managers to work across disciplines
to defend relationships and
understanding across the value chain
working with producers and suppliers to
understand the environmental impact and
social impact of its products so it
conducted a lifecycle analysis of the
company's top 13 brands and as you know
the life cycle analysis is a technique
that's used to thoroughly assess the
environmental impact associated with all
stages of a product's life from raw
material extraction through materials
processing manufacture distribution use
repair and maintenance so through this
connection with a broader contact
connection with the value chain Unilever
really connected with its core purpose
and built on founding value since the
1880s which were around responsible
business business developing products
that met the needs of the masses and
reformulated that core purpose to focus
on what they felt was the call for
Unilever in the 21st century and that
was to make sustainable living
commonplace so this is an image adapted
from Donella Meadows one of the great
system scientists from the 20th century
and she talks about the tension is
created let's see the staff that clear
purpose in this cake making sustainable
living commonplace and really
understanding your current reality and
the importance of really holding both of
those create a creative tension that
forces realignment and change and
progress hopefully towards achieving
your purpose and this is where the adapt
orientation comes in where businesses
then need to think about how do they
need to change in reorient to achieve
for purpose in the context of current
reality
Paul Coleman came out and said we must
develop a business model aimed at
contributing to society and the
environment instead of taking from them
somehow you can figure out you know what
this business model to look like that
will achieve that and so they developed
a business model that situated itself
around sustainable living basically the
idea was that profitable volume growth
would occur through innovations that
bring you sustainability benefits to
consumers and retailers that reducing
waste and energy by thinking about
sustainability and looking at lifecycle
analysis would save cost and that risk
could be managed in the supply chain
which was sure long-term sustainable
sourcing of materials and long term
viability of operations so as through
this business plan it set out a vision
and a series of goals called the
sustainable living plan it was a vision
to double the size of their business
while reducing its environmental
footprint and increasing positive impact
the positive social impact of the
business this was out in 2010 as a
10-year vision for profitable and
sustainable growth within the plan three
concrete goal for identified to help
more than 1 billion people can prove
their health and well-being
by 2020 to have the environmental
footprint of Unilever products and to
still work 100% of agricultural raw
material sustainably and enhance the
likelihoods millions of people around
the value chain so again this is back to
that expansion not just of connection
but sense of responsibility throughout
the value chain within the sustainable
living plan or nine goals or our own
goals
they sent around three areas the
improving health well-being reducing
environmental impact and enhancing
livelihood and of course goals need
metrics to ensure there's progress and
Unilever is a very strong on
elgyn over 50 targets associated with
the goals and then tracking progress in
employment progress against those
targets so in this case this is the 2014
sustainable living plan summer is
progress and one you know example for
example is the health and hygiene and
the goal was to help 1 billion people
improve hygiene habits by 2014 Unilever
had reached 397 million people to
sanitation safe drinking water and
hand-washing campaign it has also been
reporting financial and non-financial
indicators next to one another to also
cultivate that awareness among all
stakeholders the board all the way down
to and consumers that it is tracking
both of these things so here you can see
at the top the more traditional
financial indicators and below
non-financial indicators around
manufacturing for example looking at
carbon generated and water use per ton
of production waste sent to disposal and
also issued around employee engagement
and diversity that are being tracked and
all this is happening in the context of
Unilever share price doing quite well
with two red lines there on those two
graphs compared to the S&P 500 on the
left and a footsie 100 on the right so
Unilever continues to show positive
financial indicators and in 2014 at 50%
of this growth came from the sustainable
living brands they grew at twice the
rate of the business of the other the
rest of business so in addition to
aligning goal and metrics with
sustainability as we discussed earlier
aligning culture in sentences is
critical so in univers pursued a full
integration of the sustainable living
plan into its culture there are two
board committees entirely responsible
for evaluating progress making
recommendations critiquing issues
related to the sustainable
plan called Holmen early on decided not
to issue quarterly reports he wanted to
underscore management belief that
investing sustainability takes time and
the enumeration is tied to achieving
targets associated with the sustainable
living plan so in addition to align the
incentives of the culture one core
aspect of culture change is developing a
learning orientation how could unity
were developed a learning organization
so that it would not just reorient once
but continue to reorient and adapt as
conditions change and through a better
understanding of its environment
so with embarking on quite expensive
employee training and development
endeavors both communicating the core
purpose of the institution as well as
trying to cultivate growth mindset and
other systems thinking approaches
amongst its employees it's also really
pursued the idea that involving
employees is central to helping them
understand and feel committed and
engaged with with the purpose of the
organization and a couple of examples of
how it's done that include the Dove
self-esteem project where the soap has
been associated with the opportunity to
educate girls between the ages of
eighteen seventeen on the beauty comes
from within and help combat some of the
issues that young women are facing in
terms of body image employers have been
very involved in rolling out those
campaigns in diverse countries and
similarly help a child age 5 campaign is
a campaign that has been teaching
children and their parents about the
importance of hand washing and how to do
it effectively and employees have been
very engaged in participating in those
training programs as well learning from
stakeholders is another key aspect of
adopting a learning deforming patients
and not just building your own capacity
within the organization to learn but
thinking about how you learn from
diverse stakeholders bringing as many
ideas
Table four innovation so Unilever is one
example of universality sustainable
living lab which was a scaled approach
to stakeholder engagement where it
engaged over 2,000 on stakeholders from
70 countries in a 24-hour live dialogue
to critique and reflect on progress
within the sustainable living plan thus
far and to gain new ideas for how to
make better progress so moving to an
adapter innovate orientation once the
organization is reoriented and is
aligning culture and learning with
sustainability how can it then move to
platforms innovation so one of the
things that Unilever has put a lot of
emphasis on is designing you products
and business models that tackle
sustainability challenges the sunlight
and likely filters are two great
examples lifebuoy soap in particular is
when you can see the children's hands
turning green there and they designed
this silk so that would turn green once
children have washed their hands long
enough to eliminate 99.9% of germs
they also used it down we designed the
formulation so that it was a foam wash
though it was more relevant to places
with water scarcity it requires a third
less water because of the foam soap and
then finally by doing research on the
germs that cause cholera and typhoid and
I skin infection the most significant
causes of inputs to infant mortality a
number the regions where they work they
reformulated the actual chemical
composition of the soaps to be ten times
more effective at killing those
particular germs and then as we saw in
the prior slide launching campaigns to
really help educate consumers both in
terms of issues of water scarcity but
also in terms of the benefits of
hand-washing for sustainability and
likelihood circular economy is another
area where Unilever has has innovated
they are taking the traditional model of
take make waste which is you know taste
products in the environment
take resources from a national
environment based products use them for
a limited period of time and then
dispose of them to thinking much more in
a circular way in a sentient and natural
systems pursue a circular approach to
waste where all waste is recycled and
reused by the system so Unilever has
incentivized some groups throughout
supply chain come to think about
circular economy opportunities and some
ideas include using tea bags for
wallpaper they've gotten plastic
laminate that used to go into landfills
could be now used for school desks man
is turning into biofuel so a lot of
creativity happening in their journey to
zero waste the other thing they're doing
is designing and partnering for
sustainability and by engaging broad
participation problem solving and Cori
incentive programs that they used to
fund projects globally that are having a
significant impact on carbon reductions
they are also crowdsourcing
sustainability through the innovation
Unilever foundry it's an open innovation
platform and you need were post
challenges and it opens it up to global
participation and collaboration finally
Unilever has been a leader in terms of
working with unlikely bedfellows and
partnering for sustainability back in
the late 1990s Unilever formed a
partnership with World Wildlife Fund the
global conservation organization to
launch the moon stewardship council a
certification and eco leg length
organization that would help create
economic incentives for sustainable
fishing by certifying those fisheries
with good practice and allowing products
from those fisheries to bury me so label
it also is more recently working with a
tropical forest Alliance a group of
governments and consumer goods companies
who are dedicating to eliminating
deforestation entirely from the supply
chain of consumer goods companies and
figuring out strategies to address that
challenge so let's turn briefly to
sustainable harvest a second company
a specialty coffee importer that sells
certified specialty coffee from about 18
countries approximately 20 million
pounds important each year and of them
as benefits of certified US fair trade
coffee sustainable harvest started in
the late 1980s when its founder Dave
Griswold was volunteering in Mexico for
a coffee organization but supported
farmers and met Pedro a farmer who came
and represented 40 families and handed
Dave a bag of coffee this is really good
coffee I come from Mary the state in
Mexico and we need help finding we sell
our coffee to help us and so what they
did is he sawed about what this meant
the fact that there was such a
disconnect in the global market where
farmers were producing coffee but they
had no idea how to act as his local
market they were just filling on local
exchanges nor did the global market have
any sense of connection to to farmers
and actually the potential source of
great quality coffee so he decided to
form an organization dedicated to making
this connection and making a market work
in favor of small holders of coffee
farmers he looked at the global
operating environment recognized the
market shocks low commodity prices
climate change and industry
consolidation that coffee farmers were
facing and and he invented a new
business model he decided to go from a
more traditional linear supply chain
model to a much more circular value
chain so he coined this relationship
coffee and the idea was that there would
be full transparency across the value
chain that all producers would have
access to full information as was
everyone involved in every step of the
value chain so all prices and costs were
worth made transparent and shared but
more importantly relationships were
built between those individuals so that
sector white issues could be discussed
and solutions could be found he claims
the purpose of the organization is
helping farmers move from subsistence
ability so thinking about really taking
having an impact on some of the 25
million smallholder coffee farmers who
are struggling subsistence and moving
them to a viable business a sustainable
business model one of those steps he did
to reorient his company in addition
which is already quite strongly founded
on social economic and environmental
vision was to become a big corporation
or a benefit corporation in 2008 and
hold the organization accountable to a
series of metrics that these
corporations are accountable to these
corporations are approved to be in fact
required to be if you get a big
corporation status to be dedicated to
social environmental and financial
impact and then they are monitored
accordingly in sustainable harvest if
you see see on this bridge performs
quite well even relative to other B
Corporation a second study took was to
align culture and incentives so to
really think about all the different
aspects of compensation hiring practices
transparency and connection to farmers
so as one example compensation the most
highly compensated employee in his
company is a ratio of five to one to the
lowest common employer in the United
States hiring practices quite
interesting he hired four systems
thinkers not coffee specialists she
looks to people who have shown interest
in other cultures speaking other
language and think out in integrative
way then he teaches them core skills
around the coffee industry in terms of
the learning orientation one of the
primary ways sustainable harvest has
developed its learning is through an
event that they run now for several
years called let's talk coffee it's an
event that's held in most usually in a
coffee growing country and it brings
together all of the members of the value
chain to talk about upcoming issues what
are the issues they're not on top of
that they anticipate coming down the
pipe for the coffee industry what are
producers
what are the needs of Roasters how do
they problem solve together and how they
anticipate future challenges in addition
a lot of deals get done at liftop Coffee
is Roasters meat producers and get to
know their particular coffees and
stories but most importantly is an
opportunity to really problem-solve and
continue to learn together innovation
and one of the ways in which sustainable
harvest innovates is routing products
and services tastes if I on the left is
a product that they designed this won
several awards for innovation that
really does for coffee what we have for
wine which is a way of rating wines and
sharing information between producers
and retailers of that product the
question coffee is a new brand that they
developed to help to help farmers really
work directly with fire customer so
linking promise directly to customers
and helping you understand what the
issues are the farmers are facing and
helping educate consumers about
questioning the coffee supply chain and
finally they've had a huge emphasis on
farmer training technology the company
files back 90% of gross revenues into
farmer training and support including
the precious page for the coffee
purchase from farmers technologies
include water saving technology for
coffee processing but also really high
tech strategies for thinking about how
to understand the last mile of coffee
production where you can look at
individual farmer plots and see how they
connect to particular coffees that are
produced in and understand the profile
of the coffee from from a very micro
scale an individual plot and through
West aisle coffee and other platforms
and the deep relationships they built
through their relationship coffee model
they've been able to engage broad
participation in problem solving so when
the right prices work out in 2013 a
fungus that was dramatically affecting
coffee plants
Central America in particular
sustainable harvest was positioned to
both perceive the problem very quickly
because it has very regular visits to
its producers on the ground through its
origin offices these offices based in
countries of origin where the coffee is
grown so they were able to perceive the
problem quickly and through their
relationships will leverage science if
an agronomist to really figure out what
were the best approaches for averting
the spread of the disease addressing
plants that were already diseased
educating farmers so that they know the
trade-offs between different approaches
like the use of fungicides or not and
they convened several lists tough roya
events where they brought different
stakeholders together provided training
tips to farmer responded to questions
even brought in lenders to help consider
how to assist the farmers with
multi-year loans for replanting a number
of their farms that events have so badly
damaged and then similar to a Unilever
working creatively with ever partnership
sustainable harvest have done the same
they in addition to working with
certifiers
to validate and third-party certify
their fair trade and ecologically um
sustainably grown coffee and root
Capital one of the lenders they work
with they formed a major partnership at
Bloomberg to use the on profit capital
to reach tens of thousands of Rwandan
women who are displaced and who for me
coffee growing is a wonderful
opportunity for building a sustainable
livelihood so through these programs of
training and support Rwandan women have
been able to not just rope a copy but
cultivate premium quality coffee and
reach reaching them directly so as we
think about these examples and what
means for building a sustainable
organization we have lots of data in
terms of the Harvard Business Review
report that summarizes recent academic
research and business experience related
to why you know what the business case
is for integrating sustainability at the
core and we've got a global move by
groups of
to think about the UN sustainable
development goals for example the 17
goals that the United Nations has put
forward as our goals of a global
community to achieve sustainable
development and you know how to use
articulating the 12 trillion dollar
opportunity that those goals prevent so
what does this mean for for your
business it's about reflecting on how
your purpose might align with
sustainability and then thinking about
how to use orientations that will help
drive you towards progress both in terms
of achieving maximizing the impact of
your purpose and thriving in the context
of a highly complex and changing
environment
I think Paul Polman sums it up best when
he says we are at a turning point in
history the point where we all need to
change for human life on the planet to
continue to prosper a new business model
with sustainability at its heart is
vital for quality of life around the
globe to improve only the businesses
that graph this will survive only those
who go sustainably will thrive so I'm
looking forward to your thoughts and we
can take a few questions
but first I'm going to turn it over to
Romy Shiloh's who will give you a bit of
information about our upcoming
enrollment program
thank you very much Julia this was
extremely interesting and I think also
inspiring tipping to all of us listening
to the webinar to think about how we
might be able to look differently at the
organizations that we work in and
contribute to a more sustainable society
over time so with that I'd like to turn
it over to Julia and will will engage in
a few questions that we'll be taking
again we'll answer as many questions as
we can in the short time that we have
and a reminder that the recording of the
webinar will be sent to all of you who
have been on the line with us today so
that you can review the material again
so doing a one question that has come in
has to do with the relationship
difference and similarities between
corporate sustain courses responsibility
CSR and at the same
and how you see that connection great
question and I think it is quite
different corporate sustainability of
course there's a whole range and
spectrum so one mustn't oversimplify
that corporate social responsibility can
often not be linked to core purpose of
the organization so it could be for
example the donation of products
associated with that business to people
who need them computers and classrooms
or backpacks with particular products to
children in different schools
sustainability at the core is quite
different it means that you're basically
putting sustainability as core to your
strategy and designing your entire
business model and strategy around
sustainability objectives so really
looking at how you know back to you know
connecting with your environment and
understanding and building relationships
in your value chain understanding the
social and environmental impact of your
your production processes and your
product reorienting your whole system so
that it aligns with the goal of
sustainability which means taking
significant action internally to track
different kinds of metrics and and
that's obviously at one extreme but in
an innovative course for sustainability
where you're looking at new business
models like the circular economy or
collaborative consumption new ways of
creating and sustainable sourcing and
sustainable value change so that it is
fully permeated throughout your
organization so you've given examples of
two kind of for-profit companies that
have been tackling this challenge of
sustainability what are some ways that
you've seen nonprofit and government
organizations engage in these type of
activity well there's been a big shift I
would say in last 20 years to really
sort of blur the lines between the
different sectors of society and at
least think of the government as
providing some basic services civil
society they sort of the watchdog of
industry and Industry linear to maximize
profits and I think what we're starting
to see is that in the modern context
with the kinds of challenges that we're
facing in the 21st century stakeholders
are working
around a new social compact where
business government and civil society
need to find collaborative models for
working together to solve complex
challenges I think the tropical forest
Alliance is a great example where
governments of countries that are
suffering from significant deforestation
Indonesia for example losing a lot of
tropical laid fork because of palm oil
production has a lot of stake in
thinking you know getting businesses who
are driving that deforestation to think
differently and then the businesses were
competitors who are gone palm oil have a
lot to make it working together because
if one business okay we'll take
deforestation out of our supply chain
but the other competitors don't they
will certainly lose competitive
advantage at least in the short term so
this collaboration between competitors
within business engaging governments and
then also civil society organizations
who often have a lot of scientific and
community knowledge in terms of how to
make change are really essential great
so we've had a number of questions come
up around metrics and measuring success
I think you've shared a number of
examples from Unilever Unilever on how
they measure both their financial impact
as well as their sustainability or
environmental impact what can you do you
have other examples from other companies
or what should somebody think about as
they're designing some metrics for their
organization well I think first is doing
the thorough you know having a thorough
understanding of what the impacts are
and of course having a clear
understanding of what your what your
goals are and then designing custom
metrics accordingly but certainly the
templates that are out there I think the
big corporation template is a great
template it looks at all the you know
environmental social and gentlement
governance factors so Human Rights is
becoming stronger and stronger issue now
and most certifications you don't
actually address that yet so businesses
that are kind of at the forefront back
to kind of perceiving changes in the
environment and anticipating and
responding they are perceiving that
human rights
becoming a bigger and bigger issue on
slave labor and other labor right issues
and so they are already proactively
tackling those even though this work
systems and metrics and measurement
tools are not yet in place sustainable
harvest for example developed its own
system where it's um uses its staff at
the origin offices to go and conduct
surveys of producer groups to identify
whether or not there are any issues
related to to slave labor it's not yet
third-party certified but it's at least
one indicator to sustainable harvest if
there are problems and issues there so
it's part looking at the models that are
out there and then it's heart
anticipating and perceiving what are
becoming current concerns and then
designing your own tools that suit your
own industry great another question that
came up had to do with geographies so
are there particular geographies where
you see more energy and activity around
us or where this is perhaps more
required or is this more of a global
level activity and that's a very good
question I mean of course there are
different drivers in different regions
but if you look at the developing world
economic terms called emerging markets I
like to consider it in a more developing
countries there are a lot of challenges
that are being faced there in terms of
resource scarcity move from rural to
urban environments and the stress that
places on already strained
infrastructure and so there are
tremendous opportunities for innovation
there and one thing Unilever has
recognized and and other major companies
has recognized that if they don't use
their bases in these countries to
innovate in response to these incredible
challenges there are plenty of local
competitors emerging who are taking on
those challenges and innovating so in a
sense they have to reorient that way and
build their local capacity to innovate
in response to some of these challenges
in terms of sustainability demand from
consumers there certainly is a lot more
in the United States and Europe that's
driving a lot of the requests for
product that can be certified as
sustainable so it really depends where
you look but again taking assistance per
second these are global Channel
and the key is to the Orient based on
where you have impact to along with the
sustainability challenges and goals all
right so we are thank you very much
really we're at the top of the hour so
we do not have time for additional
questions but this I hopefully you all
have enjoyed the webinar and the
information that has been presented as
much as I have I'd like to encourage all
of you again to visit our website global
impact stanford.edu and find out more
information about the program that we'll
be offering in September and hopefully
some and there are many of you can join
us there and we will also having
additional webinars and we'll be sending
along information on upcoming webinars
on this topic so with that I wish you
always good rest of your day and look
out for the recording of the webinar
which should be coming to you within the
week have a great day everyone